cabine de toilette cabine de douche ou
cabines de change - regardez je vous
fais des démonstrations la gouaille d'un
bonimenteur et l'esprit d'un géo
trouvetou à la foire de paris
jérémy jahn est comme un poisson dans
l'eau le normand trentenaire est venu
présenter une invention qui lui trotte
dans la tête depuis ses 17 ans il cabine
d'intimité pour retirer le sel vous
allez à la plage vous avez besoin de
vous changez vous avez vous à les
accrocher au coffre de la voiture
ça vous permet de vous changer à longs
trajets en voiture à pipe urgent vous
allez pouvoir l'accrocher et faire votre
besoin avant il était mais tu es venu
pour les cas humanitaires c'est à dire
pour pouvoir fournir un corps un coin
hygiène aux causes humanitaires
un tuyau d'eau ils peuvent se doucher un
trou dans le sol peut voir des toilettes
parce qu'on en exode qu'on n'a pas droit
à sa dignité et ensuite le produit peut
être décliné dans pleins pleins
d'endroits un petit point blanc l'a
battu pour les rejoint avec cette
production du produit et son système de
repliage facile terminé c'est pour le
cannet participent cette année s'est
tous les jeux à son premier concours
lépine c'est génial là c'est vraiment
extra on achète on avait tout de suite
en 1 vannes donc on va le mettre
derrière
pourquoi la douche c'est parfait salaire
baisser leur pratique c'est pas lourd
c'est léger ça peut se mettre dans un
sac même en moto parce qu'on est on est
en moto donc ouais non c'est bien ça va
et jérémie janot lui a plus d'un tour
dans son sac avec pas moins de neuf
autres idées pour l'avenir
nourrie aux histoires de mickey se
touchaient tous autodidactes bricoler un
vente depuis ses plus jeunes années
des pics où je les ai des mangas je
voyais des inventions jettent rage
depuis tout petit je suis comme ça on
m'appelle je trouve tout dur commence
pour moi c'est une passion c'est un
travail
aujourd'hui plus qu'une victoire au
concours lépine
il espère inondé les plages de sa cabine
d'intimité
bientôt disponible chez les géants
d'internet
[Musique]
et